today Michigan becomes the first state
to ban flavored east cigarettes the
governor said it's meant to protect
young people from the potentially
harmful effects of vaping the band
covers retail and online sales it goes
into effect immediately but businesses
have 30 days to comply it does not cover
tobacco flavored cigarettes which is
kind of interesting you've done a lot of
report yeah so that's an interesting a
carve-out it's a bit worrying because
you know on Friday the CDC which is
tracking 215 cases of lung illness said
don't buy bootleg cigarette products and
don't modify the products well when you
create a band it doesn't that's a pretty
strong push toward a black market and I
would worry that that people are gonna
get more stuff off the street not less
and it could be more dangerous as a
result and now they cook to the candy to
the sweet stuff or the tobacco well
that's I sort of have always asked that
question what is the impetus for having
these flavors like Froot Loops and they
sound short but I mean there really
isn't there's a genuine hash tag among
adult ex-smokers turn bakers
adults love flavors too they want a
break from what a cigarette is they want
a new companion in their pocket and they
like flavors and it makes it feel
different and also the same and that's
what they need to quit for some people
yeah all right so the regulation goes
into effect very quickly it's going to
be a ban on using billboards also to
advertise for e-cigarettes what's
interesting